this is a Louisiana pine snake if we
didn't show it to you you'd probably
never see it or it's distinct yellow and
Brown splotch scales it's one of the
rarest snakes in North America the
Louisiana pine snake can grow up to six
feet long it's not poisonous it's a
constrictor it wraps its prey and
suffocates them it's 9:00 habitat is
estimated to be less than 200 square
miles in the longleaf pine forests on
the Louisiana Texas border a habitat
that is only 3% of its once massive size
it's almost impossible to spot in the
wild because the snake spends its time
below ground moving through the tunnels
of its rodent prey but when it pokes its
head above ground its habitat is in
steady decline fewer trees mean fewer
rodents barring beneath and that means
fewer pine snakes and with encouraging
human development the ever-present
threat of being crushed under road
traffic looms this is Louisiana pine
snake
this is the Guatemalan beaded lizard
it's bite can be deadly but we're a
larger threat to it than it is to us
there are less than 200 of these
creatures left in the wild making it one
of the most endangered lizards in the
world their beaded black skin is adorned
with yellow spots and bands they can be
found mainly in deserts and dry forests
but even then they're hard to find as
they spend about 70% of their lives
underground measuring up to a foot and a
half when fully grown they can pack a
serious punch they are one of only two
lizard species that are venomous the
venom is in their saliva and it's
administered when they bite their prey
unfortunately this venom also strikes
fear among humans the biggest threat to
these otherwise docile creatures hunting
habitat loss and poaching have forced
this phantom lizard to fight for its
survival this is the Guatemalan beaded
lizard
you
this is the spider tortoise these little
guys are so endangered that scientists
say that they could completely vanish in
the next 15 years the spider tortoise is
hard to find for one they're tiny one of
the smallest known land turtles rarely
reaching more than 6 inches in length
another reason they only inhabit a tiny
sliver of Madagascar's southwestern
coast their name comes from the web like
patterns on their shells during the dry
season they bury themselves in the sand
and re-emerge when it rains to feed on
leaves roots and insects just because
they're tiny doesn't mean they're young
they're estimated to live up to 70 years
in the wild these little guys are up
against a lot the largest concern is
that they are still hunted locally for
food but the illegal pet trade and
shrinking habitat are all threats to
their survival this is the spider
tortoise
this is a Chinese alligator native to
eastern China it is so rare that there
are only a hundred and thirty left in
the wild
known as the Yangtze alligator it is one
of the smallest crocodilians in the
world their stocky body is covered in
hard scales on the back and it's blunt
teeth are perfect for crushing shelled
animals like clams and snails their menu
also includes fish insects birds and the
occasional small mammal they stay in
subtropical areas with freshwater
sources like lakes ponds marshes and
streams sadly these habitats are
disappearing often to make room for
agriculture this and perching are the
biggest threats to the survival of the
species
luckily they do well in captivity as
they have been successfully bred in
wildlife refuges and zoos this is the
Chinese alligator
this is the rally's palm pit viper and
it's as dangerous as it is rare there
are 10 species of pompeii / that inhabit
the cloud forests of Central America but
of all of them
the rally's is the most rare and elusive
it can only be found on three isolated
mountains in southern Mexico brilliant
green and slender these Vipers will
spend most of their lives quote quietly
in trees and other vegetation they are
not aggressive by nature but will strike
if disturbed a bite from a rallies is
not likely to be fatal to humans but be
warned
nurse Pacific anti-venom exists for this
extraordinary species of snake while not
necessarily a threat to us Thurs that
should be worried are the small mammals
and tree frogs that the Viper preys upon
doors that stray too close we'll meet a
swift and silent end but even these
venomous predators can't stave off
bigger threats deforestation and OVA
collection for the pet trade are
perilous threats for this rare animal
this is the rallies palm pit viper
this is a Japanese giant salamander it
is massive
this primeval amphibian can grow up to
five feet long and weigh over 50 pounds
making it one of the largest salamanders
to ever crawl the face of the earth
despite its primitive look the Japanese
giant salamander is highly evolved it is
covered head to tail with specialized
cells that detect tiny vibrations in its
environment when it detects a threat it
excretes a strong smelling O's that
smells like a Japanese pepper hence it's
common Japanese name giant pepper fish
the Japanese giant salamander is
entirely aquatic and spends its life in
clear cool flowing streams it has no
gills but instead absorbs oxygen through
its skin if left alone the Japanese
giant salamander will live a long life
this one is 26 years old and in the wild
they can live to be nearly 80 but
pollution of its River habitat and order
collection are threatening this
fascinating primordial creature this is
the Japanese giant salamander
this is the Panamanian golden frog a
frog so rare it may no longer exist in
the wild merely inches in size this
frogs ornate skin is stunning but also
quite poisonous the frog is covered in
deadly toxins to protect itself from
predators in the wild it feasts on
insects that it finds near streams in
the mountainous rainforests of Panama
but a combination of deforestation
poaching and a devastating fungal
disease laid waste to their population
but there is still hope for this special
amphibian breeding in captivity has been
successful and continued efforts are
being made to protect and preserve their
habitats
this is the Panamanian golden frog
this is the Blandings turtle look
closely because they're hard to spot in
the wild
Blandings turtles aren't very big
topping out at around ten inches in
length what distinguishes them is
they're bright yellow chin and throat
like the stereotype Blandings turtles
take their time however once they've
reached full adulthood there's no
slowing down a recent study found an 83
year old female that was full of eggs
ready to lay their general habitat is
wetlands with shallow water their range
is centered around the Great Lakes
extending east to New York and up to
southern Ontario but the wetlands they
call home are shrinking and becoming
fragmented from human development the
biggest threat to the survival of this
gentle and timid creature this is the
Blandings turtle